[Music]
today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon and let's get right into it
chris today's topic
questionable position groups in the
aftermath of the 2021 draft scale of 1
to 10
how concerned are you about and we'll
begin with the steelers offensive line
given that marquis pouncey center long
time fixture on the offensive line is
retired alejandro villanueva left tackle
gone for the ravens matt filer signed by
the chargers they drafted kendrick green
a guard out of illinois in round three a
tackle dan moore in round four how
concerned are you currently about that
steelers offensive line scale of one to
ten uh i would say i'm going to go about
a seven right now with that right there
i mean
yeah there's a lot of moving
parts there with that that team
at that position and of course we know
that it's a
a position or a group a unit that
they want to improve and start to play
through more that way so i guess what i
yeah i'm concerned because there's
unproven commodities there there's no
doubt about it and i'm not sure about
some of these guys they're gonna fill
these holes so i like some of the draft
picks certainly um but yeah i mean
there's definitely concern when you have
a quarterback like big ben
roethlisberger and you know lack of a a
true big time running back too
i spoke yesterday with kevin colbert the
steelers gm about the running game about
where they think they need to improve it
and obviously he
acknowledged there's a certain amount of
projection that goes into the offensive
line that they're hopefully can create
holes for their first round draft pick
naji harris from alabama giants and i'll
agree with you what number did you say i
think i said six or seven i think seven
yes uh uh i'll you know i'll i'll i'll
see your seven and i'll make it an eight
because
that offensive line is going to be a key
to whether or not the steelers can
effectively run the ball or throw the
ball and they have to protect ben
roethlisberger in what could be the last
year of his career and it's more likely
to be the last year of his career if
this offensive line doesn't come
together quickly remember it wasn't that
long ago this was a team that somehow
won a couple of super bowls with a
horrible offensive line 05 and 08
horrible they got a much better
offensive line but they haven't gotten
back to the super bowl that's been the
irony of how great their offensive line
has become
now it's a work in progress yeah
they needed to show progress quickly so
i'll say an eight because i think it
really could affect the steelers in a
bad way all right giant's offensive line
scale of one to ten how concerned are
you about that unit i i'm not gonna sit
here and tell you that i'm like overly
concerned about it i'm gonna go like a
five maybe yeah it wasn't per it's not
perfect that offensive line but it kind
of turned the corner you know
towards the end of last year to where it
started going in the right direction and
they've got a lot of assets there i
expect andrew thomas their first rounder
to be better from last year you do have
nate solder coming back you know we've
talked about
leading up to the draft you know there's
still will hernandez at right guard
who's a second round pick from a few
years ago so you know i mean decent
center play
uh i'm not like overly concerned about
the giants up front i think it's more
about them just you know playing and
continuing to get better with some of
these younger guys
kevin zeitler right guard was cut zach
fulton was signed from the texans nate
solder is back from his opt-out he's not
going to be the left tackle that's
andrew thomas how are they going to use
nate's soldier i would think that maybe
they try to ask him to go over to the
right side i would think that's going to
be part of that conversation unless they
felt like andrew thomas maybe could go
back over to the right side because he
has done that a little bit in college
where he played that side and maybe they
let nate solder end his career out at
left tackle though they're gonna have to
play around with that a little bit but
you know i would think ultimately
they're gonna find a way to get both
guys on the field
how about the weapons in the titans
passing game scale of one to ten how
concerned are you corey davis a top five
pick several years ago signed with the
jets tight end john who smith leaves for
the patriots they added josh reynolds
from the rams they drafted dez
fitzpatrick out of louisville in round
four and racy mcmath out of lsu in round
six
one to ten how concerned are you about
the options that ryan tannehill has in
the passing game well i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go with like a st uh i'm gonna say
a five here again i'm not overly
concerned i'm not first off we know
they're going to run the football that's
what they want to do josh reynolds is
one of those receivers that you know the
world doesn't really know about really
how good he is and everything like that
you know stuck out there with the rams
and was kind of the third option and
everything like that but they have
decent tight end play already it was
already you know i know jonah smith
that's a tough loss but still it's a
position that's kind of deep there on
that tennessee titan roster so i'm not
overly concerned about it they got an aj
brown who's a difference maker um i
still think they can make do and it's
about the run game and the play action
passes that are the big thing with
tennessee anyways
and i think having aj brown is a big key
to that but there has been i think a net
dip a conscientious strategic dip
there's only so many dollars to go
around they got to do what they can and
you never know what other moves may be
made as the offseason yeah they can
re-evaluate as they go along here right
ravens pass rush one to ten how
concerned are you when we consider that
matt judon is gone he signed with the
patriot janna gangway guy that gave up a
third round pick for gone for the
raiders
used a first round pick on an edge
rusher at number 31.
how
concerned are we about the ability of
the ravens to put heat on opposing
corners it really doesn't change a whole
lot by what they lost i mean i don't
look at ya like yannick and gottway and
judon as like sack masters anyways i
really didn't they had you know the
ravens got after teams with the blitz
more times than not and all those things
so it hasn't like
swayed my opinion as far as their rush
there's an issue there i would say for a
great defense like that i'm gonna say
like a a six is they don't have one
great pass rusher they have a lot of
good and a creative defensive
coordinator who knows how to get people
you know free to the quarterback
and you know i mean here's the bottom
line that ravens defense always finds a
way they do
there'll be another matt jude on
there'll be another yannick and gawkway
someone will emerge and someone will be
plugged in and someone will get it done
for the baltimore ravens let's take a
break when we return we're gonna flip it
around positive we have a draft of the
most improved position groups based upon
free agency in the draft we'll do that
when pft live continues right after this
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon built right for business
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports